welcome to film courage this is episode
158 I'm Karen warden and I'm David
Brandon you can find our archives on
iTunes film curse com la talk radio com
and mu B garage if you haven't heard yet
we've announced the world premiere of
our film goodbye promise yeah that's
this is not an April Fool's joke two
months from today goodbye promise is
going to be screening in Los Angeles at
the downtown independent on Friday June
first 2012 from 7pm to 11pm please visit
goodbye promised calm for the trailer
video interviews and ticket information
our feeling is that it's going to sell
out so we encourage you to purchase
tickets in advance today's guests are
Steve James and Alex Kotlowitz the
filmmakers behind this year's film
independent spirit award winner the
interrupter 'he's the interrupters is a
documentary which spotlights the
fascinating stories of three violence
interrupters working to protect their
chicago communities from the violence
they too were once a part of the film
follows Ameena Matthews Cody Williams
and Eddie Bocanegra as they go about
their work in the community in the midst
of processing their own past experiences
with the very things they are working to
prevent inspiring hope and redemption
among people in the crossfire as well as
themselves shot over the course of a
year out of carts and Quinn films the
interrupter is captures a period in
Chicago when it became a national symbol
for the violence in our cities during
that period the city was besieged by
high-profile incidents most notably the
brutal beating of Darien Albert a
Chicago high school student whose death
was caught on videotape the film
attempts to make sense of what
ceasefires tio Hardiman calls simply
quote the madness you may also know
steve james from the 94 documentary hoop
dreams and Alex from the best-selling
book there are no children here the
story of two boys growing up in the
other America please welcome to film
courage via telephone Steve James and
alex collier wits welcome gentlemen
thanks so much for joining us today
Peter having us no thanks
yeah thank you you know we first want to
thank both of you for extending your
press tour to appear on film courage
here today you know we know that you've
been talking about this film for the
past 18 months and we're just super
grateful to have you guys extend it you
know that the join us here today yeah
thank you and we'd also like to give a
big thanks to tim horsburgh and i hope
i'm saying his name correctly of a good
of kardam Quinn films in Chicago for
arranging this interview today and you
can find out more about kardam Quinn
calm and at Carnac win on Twitter
alright so Alex will jump right in and
we'll start with you where did you work
before you became a journalist and an
author before I became a journalist and
author when I when I got out of college
Jim it is a long time ago I worked on a
cattle ranch for a year and then found
my way to an alternative newspaper in
Michigan which is where I begin my work
as a journalist and I feel answer five
years and then actually was a correspond
for The Wall Street Journal by covered
over in affairs for the paper oh you
didn't waste too much time at all right
yeah and I let's say about 20 years ago
to write books and magazine pieces and
now film thank you and so Steve what
about for you what before you got into
documentaries what was your what was
your day job well one is it wasn't as
romantic as that cattle ranching thing I
I mean I was a student and you know I
fell in love with film when I was in at
the end of my undergraduate days and
then ended up going to graduate school
and studying film but you know along the
way I had a you know a series of awful
jobs you know until I moved to Chicago
and and began a career in earnest you
know and Hoop Dreams was part of the
motivation to move to Chicago in
particular to start that film it was an
idea I had when I was in graduate school
mm-hmm so having those series of awful
jobs that light a fire under you because
you kind of said you know what I'm so
sick of this I need to do something
well yeah I mean you know it i mean i
think it's sort of it's sort of what you
do you know my daughter just graduated
from scripps out there and you know
she's working at a cafe in san diego a
beachside cafe side doesn't sound too
bad but it's not you know it's not the
kind of job she wants or it's going to
do with her education so you know it's I
think jobs like that can can kind of
focus your mind on what it is you really
want to do and I think it's a pretty
typical path for a lot of young young
people agreed yeah Alex why are you so
drawn to writing about poverty violence
and education um you know for me I've
been to really more than anything I
things on to writing about Outsiders you
know people on the outside looking in
and I think often because I think people
on the outside have a much clearer
perspective about what's going on I also
think you can serve take a measure of
society by how we sort of end up
treating the most vulnerable and so for
my first book you know for instance
spending time with these two young boys
and public housing projects and what had
to be one of the worst neighborhoods and
certainly in chicago from at nationwide
you sort of begin to sort of take a look
at sort of where we're at as a as a
nation to how we treat in and imagine
our most vulnerable i also tell you that
there's something exhilarating about
knowing that you're telling stories
publicly for the first time stories that
haven't been told before I mean it can
be pretty exciting and I think also you
know you see people who somehow are
managing to stay erect in this otherwise
slumping world around them and it can
often as certainly was the case with the
interrupters he'd be incredibly
inspiring mmm Steve why are you drawn to
these similar themes um you know I think
I think for me some of the roots of it
were growing up I grew up in Hampton
Virginia small city down on in the
Tidewater area and you know I grew up in
a in a city that was very much
a black and white community substantial
black population a place where race and
class were not really talked about much
and there was a high level of civility
in in people's you know general goings
and comings in that community but there
were these fissures and tensions that
underscored it and i think i felt that
fairly acutely in part through my
participation in sports in basketball in
particular you know it sort of brought
me into contact with people on the other
side of the tracks if you will and and
on the other side of the racial divide
and i think that that was probably where
the seeds were planted and it was sort
of as i got older and got interested in
film and started to care about well what
goes on in the world I think issues of
race and class kind of came to the fore
for me in that regard okay well now the
two of you seem to have to us at least
looking as Outsiders the ideal situation
you've made your vocation your
occupation and that's something that all
of us want to do we want to monetize our
passions and things like that what was
the turning point in your careers how
are you able to cross the threshold you
mean being able to monetize our passion
so she says yeah yeah and I have a
career right I mean so many people you
know it's a hobby you know whether it's
a blogger or whatever it is and and
they'd love to be able to quit that day
job and do something else how are you
able to turn the corner with that either
one of you let him speak for myself I
mean I you know I so began my career as
a journalist and so had a series of jobs
first of this alternative news weekly
and then at the wall street journal
where I thought I'd last maybe a couple
of years ends up staying for a decade
and it was probably as good a job as you
could get in daily journalism and that
they really let me go off and tell the
kinds of stories I
as a toe and but for me it was really
writing my first book it's what I think
gave me the ability to really sort of
set out on my own and and carve out a
career writing doing radio and some film
and you know finding ways to tell these
stories that for me we're exciting were
you know filled with surprises stories
reuse sort of felt like you were having
some impact and it's a pretty good life
having said that I could tell you that
it's also it's it's a bit of a roller
coaster you've got these periods that
I'm in one right now where you're so
trying to find your way to your next
project and you sort of look down the
horizon you think my god what am I going
to am I gonna get my claws into
something right yes yeah for me well for
me it was not dissimilar I mean I didn't
really when I got out of graduate school
moved to Chicago I started to work my
way up the food chain in in commercial
filmmaking you know and primarily TV
commercials there's a there was a
vibrant industry here where you could
you could work and make a living and it
was a it was sort of an ideal thing for
me because I was pursuing this this you
know this passion project you might call
it hoop dreams on the side so I could
work in the commercial business and I
could work for a few weeks at a time
doing everything from the most
humiliating tasks as a production
assistant to eventually working my way
up to a little bit better position but I
always knew that I could you know a good
thing was is that when I was done with a
particular job I could take a couple of
weeks and go work on this thing that
nobody was going to pay you to do and
and so you know I think and again just
as Alex talked about his first book
being kind of a watershed for me you
know when who creams was completed and
all that happened with that film
obviously that was a you know that was a
huge turning point for me career-wise
and they really made a career possible
doing what I wanted to do which was to
rec'd films and so you know ever since
then yeah it's III know I haven't really
had a an actual staff position and you
know 27 years or so anywhere it's always
been moved from one project to the next
as i like to say sometimes you're
yourself unemployed you know as you try
to figure out what the next thing is
going to be and play like a situation
ality yeah do you find do you both find
a freedom in that it's it for some
people it could be scary and I think for
others it's exhilarating because you
don't know what the future holds and
it's it's a sort of like it's Bob I mean
I think it's one of those things where
depending on when you talk to either of
us it's either exhilarating or scary you
know you know I think it's just but I I
think I've ultimately discovered about
myself is that I really much prefer the
freedom if you can make it work I much
prefer the freedom of being my own boss
and being able to sort of pursue
projects I want to do and I've been able
to be successful in getting you know
most of them off the ground to in a way
that I could you know remain employed
sure you know how important it is it as
a writer storyteller or filmmaker to
pursue stories that speak to the core of
who you are well I I angry yeah I so go
ahead no that's cheap stuff what's that
alright students are with you yet well I
was just going to say i mean i think
that you know the core of who you are
that's kind of a tough one to know i
mean i just say i just find it over the
years though that i become interested in
a topic or something or a story and I
don't often know exactly why it is that
I'm compelled by it in some cases it's
more obvious i mean it with who claims
it was more obvious but you know I think
sometimes you don't really figure out
what it was that really fascinated you
about a given story that you pursued
until later sometimes not until it's
done or even well after a weird the way
but one of the things I've noticed over
the years with me is that I'm a lot of
the ideas for films come from thing from
places where I'm upset or disturbed by
something and it may be my own reaction
to it maybe my bed I feel like I don't
understand it and and it bothers me and
I want to understand it better and i
also find like Alex said earlier I'm
drawn to people on the margins of
society I'm drawn to people I'm drawn to
subjects for films that that most people
and as a society don't tend to deem as
worthwhile subjects for film they're not
famous they're not necessarily hugely
accomplished in any you know way that
society recognizes and so you know I
just find that that that a lot of times
it's the people that don't think their
stories are worth being told or that
have anything especially great to say or
are usually some of the more interesting
stories that often have a lot to say no
and I think you know stories you know
sort of inform who we are I mean they
help us make sense of the world in
ourselves and I think one of the sort of
glorious things about what we do if
you're doing it right is the Steve
suggested Asian every time you sort of
venture out on a story it really is this
kind of journey of discovery and and
constant astonishment and often you end
up at a very different place from where
you began and yeah and you hope that you
can sort of take readers or moviegoers
so long that same kind of journey well
where they come in with all their set of
assumptions and then leave a book or a
film look at the world just a little bit
differently and maybe looking at
themselves a little bit differently Alex
the interrupter 'he's movie begins with
you sitting in on a ceasefire meeting
for three months you then wrote an
article called blocking the transmission
of violence that was featured in new
york times magazine and then Steve reads
that article and he calls you
that same day and he says this may work
as a documentary so going back going
back to those ceasefire meetings we've
heard that you say that you know you
heard about the meetings from a friend
just curious was it your intention all
along that you were going to write about
the interrupters or you know what like
what were you trying to get from those
meetings why were you attending right
when I first went down to cease fire it
really was in some ways a kind of an
apology because I had you know I think
like a lot of people I there you can't
help but live in the city of Chicago and
not be familiar with ceasefire their
bumper stickers are ubiquitous or all
over the place and and and I thought get
one more gang intervention group and and
you know he asked that I come down to
visit them and I began attending these
wednesday meeting ta ya be sitting on
those meetings with those men and a
sphere with time they were just a few
women still are in fact but you sort of
realize I mean this is this incredible
window onto a part of the city and you
also sort of begin to sort of here sort
of the beginning here some of the
outlines of the stories of of the
personal journey so those sitting around
the table and I was just immediately
drawn in and so right away I you know
call my editor at The New York Times
Magazine and suggest that they might be
a good story here and so they gave me
the green light but while I was working
on a story Steve and I are a longtime
friends and we had we had been talking
about doing something together really in
the dramatic realm and as I was working
on this story I began thinking that well
you know she could get the kind of
access we needed it might make for
really interesting documentary I mean
just didn't Iran and you look at the
faces of those men and women around the
table and you can imagine the stories of
their own journeys and then of course
just spending time with them on the
streets and and then as you said when
Steve read the piece that someday he
called and said you know I remember well
actually Steve entities life read it and
because I remember Judy hope same way
and Steve said you know let's see if we
can you know make this work so Alex I
mean did you did you pitch Steve before
the article was published I mean because
it
the idea is not like i'm sorry steven i
talked about it I mean I was talking to
Steve about we often are telling each
other what we're working on us i was
talking about this so he knew about it
and I told him I you know now usually I
mean I've got a semi my sort of you know
my real home is as a writer and so I
don't usually think about the pieces i'm
doing is films or his documentaries this
was a really unusual instance for me and
and the only worried question your head
you were just going to say I good no no
I was just going to say that I I worry
about you know some get me kind of
intimacy that you can get in print and I
think what was clear and working with
Steve that we were going to be able to
get that I you know Steve's just a
master at that in his films and sort of
finding that intimacy with his subjects
and that's not easy with the camera and
and so then the question was active I
mean so Steve how soon was it you know
after you read this article that that
you're you know you're on the phone with
with Alex and and then and then before
long your meeting with the ceasefire
brass and the interrupter as a map how
much time passed before you you would
already dive in full payment no no time
house oh no I mean that the day came out
I think I called Alex but they have
appeared in print and yeah I mean I
think galaxy's biggest concern was you
know it had to it had been difficult for
him to be close to mediations even as a
print journalist because of the nature
of the work and and you know we go out
and I've often talked about how you know
I would say you know I'm envious of what
you're able to do in print because you
don't really have to be there in order
to make to write it in a way that makes
it feel for the audience like we are
there whereas in film yeah you can
interview people about what happened but
it ain't the same as being there and and
and that becomes crystal clear a film so
you know and then you know so I think
one of the things we talked about that
sunday was just well how could we go
about getting the kind of intimate
access and how much
intimate access would we need in order
to tell this story and we talked about
the fact that you know we're not doing
reality TV we're doing a film and in a
film you don't need analyst mediations
that you're privy to like you do in
reality television because what we want
to do with each mediation is to dig
deeper and understand it and and so with
that in mind we we fairly quickly
because of Alex's great relationship and
contacts to cease fire from doing the
article we fairly quickly went about
meeting with the ceasefire brass with
Gary selecting the founder and with tio
Hardiman the creator of the interrupters
program and then with other people on
the staff and then eventually with some
of the interrupter 'he's themselves to
really talk to them about the idea of a
film and and and talk very very
pointedly about this question of could
we get a camera to some of these
mediations and capture some of them and
we kind of came away from that process
feeling like we would be able to get
some mediations and we wouldn't be able
to be in every situation we'd be able to
get some and and so on the basis of that
we went out and shot just a couple of
days no real mediation in those couple
of days we put together a demo and began
the process of teaching it for funding
and and we were able over the course of
the next five six months to put enough
funding together to kind of launch the
film so right and we began slowly I mean
we really began by filming those
Wednesday meetings and it was a way to
get people everybody around the table
comfortable with pajama comfortable with
the process and and while we were there
tio who you know heads that the
interrupters he would urge everyone
there to call us if they thought they
could get us out on the street and we
haven't clear understanding with
everybody is that you know please just
call us whenever there's anything going
on if we get out there and it feels
unsafe or if somehow you feel
compromised by our presence or if people
didn't want to be filmed we'd walk away
and there were moments that we did but
for the most part
we were I think I me and at least I was
surprised how open people were there
having us there yeah we missed we missed
the mediations there were there were you
know it took us a while it's like every
film there's just a certain sort of
organic process that happens regardless
of the topic subject matter subjects I
think where it's always slower going in
the early stages as you get comfortable
as people as people get comfortable with
you and then and then a certain point
you kind of turn a corner and and that
access and that trust kicks in and it's
remarkable how how open people can be in
and how much access you can gain if you
put in the time and are there and that's
you know we couldn't have done the film
the way we did it if we didn't both live
here this was the kind of project where
I had the camera in my house and when a
call would come into either Alex or
myself from one of the Eruptor saying
there was a situation and we could maybe
go along we would leap into action the
two of us along with co-producers that
Piper who also did the sound work and we
would just you know we just go out we
were on call just like they were one
step removed I do what were some of the
objections can you share that with our
listeners of in terms of the ceasefire
meetings you said it was slow going at
first which I'm sure you know anybody
would be resistant to someone coming in
with a camera to their meetings but can
you share what some of those initial
thoughts of resistance work well I think
some of the interrupter there was one
interrupter we actually very much wanted
to follow and he has a family and young
kids and I think he felt and
understandably somewhat protective of
his family and so decided in the end
that he didn't want to be a part of the
film there was also another interrupter
who we followed for a while we fumble
wrought with him and his family and it
became a peer apparent over the course
of the first few months that you know he
was really uncomfortable with us going
out with him in the streets and and I I
was I can understand that I think you
know we ended up with three individual
zetia meaning probably each of them are
exceptional their own ways even with
them especially with Eddie in the Latino
community we had real difficulties in
filming the latino gang hierarchy didn't
like the idea of us filming us who we in
the end had to go film with much of our
filming with Eddie in a different
neighborhood in the classroom said not a
question and also in Cicero yeah and it
just it sort of worked out because what
fascinated us about Eddie more than
anything was the personal journey that
he was on in terms of trying to come to
terms with what he had done and and big
sort of ways in which Eddie would is a
guy that thinks outside the box in terms
of he really questions his effectiveness
and questions is there a better way and
is always looking for interesting in
different ways to reach kids and so that
kind of became his story which was great
because as Alex said when we tried to
film in his neighborhood and we did get
you no one really terrific seeing it
prompted the leader in one of the gangs
to basically say no more and and that
was that you know you know I just think
that what was special about Kobe and
mean and Eddie to is besides their
individual strengths and approaches was
that they each in different ways found
ways for us to be there that did not
compromise the work they were doing they
were able to Kobe was great at being
able to play it off as no big deal which
has always been my philosophy of
filmmaking which is to always treat it
like it's no big deal it's just a couple
of people with a camera and sound here
and nothing more and and Kobe had a way
of in the in the neighborhood just
telling people it's like you know we
were film crew and you know he would he
would just you know say there with me
and I'm coming and you know that's not
gonna be a problem right you know he
didn't you read over it and and and
again there were times when we stepped
away but but by and large it was amazing
how skilled he was at getting us into
the situation it made you realize just
how skilled he was when he was in the
streets Kobe was a very effective
guy in the streets who was well loved
and respected and we saw that very much
on display well I love to how you show
how there's such pillars of strength in
the community and to be looked up to but
then you would take this
behind-the-scenes look where they still
doubted themselves and they still you
know dealt with traumatic you know
situations of abuse and what have you
not having a father around did you know
right away that structurally and
story-wise you were going to focus the
stories on these three or possibly for
interruptus or did this was this part of
the evolution of the film you said
earlier how it just sort of developed on
its own way I can't we do researches
what's that's it go I think what we knew
is that we wanted to film a year in the
life of the city and about the violence
and the interrupter kind of be our eyes
and ears out there having said that we
didn't really know a whole lot about the
backgrounds we knew obviously with Amina
that who her father was and we knew was
that either you know that he had
committed murder when he was 18 but we
we didn't know much beyond that and so
again you know that sort of world with
stuff that we kind of discovered and to
be honest it took a while for all three
of them to really fully open up with us
I think for me at least what was real
exciting in terms of story and what was
you certainly didn't expect were kind of
all the kind of secondary characters you
meet in the film flame Oh Mikey Vanessa
Capricia and it was those stories that
we saw unfold literally before our eyes
and didn't know where they were going to
take us this past Thursday Mars 29th a
nephew of Miami Heat star Dwyane Wade
was one of 13 men shot to which were
fatal during a violent six-hour stretch
in Chicago so you know we're still
seeing this hit the news this this
epidemic is real what kind of
reservations did the two of you have at
the onset of making this film and me
because you know you're both family men
and your put
yourselves right little the storm yeah I
think well I think we we you know we
both spent a fair amount of time and in
these kinds of neighborhoods in the
course of the work we've done which is
not to say though that we feel like we
can move with impunity and do anything
we want at all but I think we we did
have a level of comfort and and that was
further sort of underscored by you know
the fact we were with Kobe Amina daddy
who carry with them tremendous respect
and credibility in these communities and
and as a result I think that um you know
we did we rarely if ever felt in any
real danger is you know and and the
truth is is that if if you're a
journalist it's not true in more
situations anymore used to be true there
but so many journalists have been killed
in war situations in the last ten years
it's remarkable but but in in situations
here in tough neighborhoods in general I
think I've found that that I feel I'm
probably one of the safest people there
because especially once people know why
you're there and what you're there for
and there is you know there's far more
danger for the residents there because
they're the ones that are getting caught
up in situations that are sometimes
personal sometimes gang related but you
know genuine altercations it's I think a
lot of people if you've not spent time
in these neighborhoods you think that if
you're a white person going into these
neighborhoods that you're automatically
targeted for attack or something or a
potential attack and it's just not true
and one of these are soon you go into a
community like Englewood where we spent
time and we're so clearly outsiders I
mean these two white men three white men
with Zack and people and then we've got
camera and sound here people want to
know who we are what we're doing and so
you do immediately sort of have this
kind of connection with people just
because of who we are so is that a
situation we're literally almost
day that you guys are filming that that
you're continually telling people like
hey this is what we're doing I mean is
that's all part of the process for you
guys yeah I mean I'm a big believer that
you answer people's questions you and
you engage people you know we don't go
in and try to be a fly on the wall that
classic cinema verite sense we go in and
through our main subjects that we're
following we engage with people and we
meet with them and we talked to them and
when they have questions we answer them
and and word gets around you know we
don't have to talk to every single
person for them to understand why we're
there and what we're about word travels
and and again the fact that we're with a
Kobe I mean already makes all the
difference in the world I mean no one
says no to amina you know about anything
and and so if we're with her that that
carries with it and you know a certain
credibility that that you can't get
otherwise and I know this from you know
I've gone out with cameras without
ecopia me and Eddie into tough
neighborhoods and I'm always very
careful in those situations not because
I'm fearful of being hurt but I'm also
I'm always very careful about you know
indicating to people exactly why I'm
there and what I'm trying to do because
people see cameras there was a time
maybe when people were enamored with the
whole idea that cameras were in the
neighborhood and they're going to be on
the evening news and all that
increasingly people want to know what
you're there for because they've seen
too many things on the evening news or
on television where their communities
been portrayed and very negative light
and they want to know what you're doing
and why and so I think it's so being
able to communicate that to people in
various ways and again because we spent
so much time there word traveled I mean
we were in we're in Kobe's car a lot
driving around anglewood and and there
were days where we filmed a lot and
there were days where we didn't feel
much at all but but we would see and
meet people and people got the message I
also to remind yourself to when you know
we're filming individuals you really
have no obligation or responsibility
that talk to us and so we're kind of
there at their invitation and and we're
asking them to be as open as they can
with us and and I think the one thing
that Steve and I one of the Steven I
share and the way we go about our work
is this feeling that we have
responsibility p is open and candid as
we can with people about what we're
doing I mean obviously you can't know
everything you but you probably we
always were as you said trying to engage
with people I mean I think we're going
to some like this somebody's having this
extended conversation you know we're not
people who go in everyone goes in with
preconceived notions yeah I mean that's
what we do in life right the great thing
about this experience is getting them
turned upside down but we always go in
even though we may have our own
preconceived notions of what we might
see in what we expect and what we think
is going on we take an approach which is
we're not the experts at all we're here
to try to understand and I think when
you genuinely communicate that to people
it's remarkable how open people in in
tough places and tough neighborhoods and
tough living situations will be because
they're so used to people not doing that
they're not used to the media coming and
they're used to the TV news coming in
when a murderer double murder happens
and doing their thing and then taking
off they're not used to people coming in
in a situation like that and sticking
around and saying okay what really is
going on here that led to this why did
this happen and we mommy you know we've
watched this movie three times this week
and just sit back and is my hat's off to
you and listening to you guys going to
the process you know it just just really
relishing this this some conversation
here we are on the line with filmmakers
steve james and alex Kotlowitz of the
2011 sundance and 2012 film independent
spirit award winning film the
interrupter so you get clearance to you
know turn the cameras on and you get an
okay from ceasefire did anything
significant
happen on your first day of filming or
did it take time for things to kind of
heat up and then different incidents
happened here I can't remember what the
first day the first the first day of
filming what is a meeting and then we
hung out with with Tim you know that was
like my way early I mean that was when
we were creating the demo and I don't
think there's anything in the demo that
we created to raise money for the film
that ended up in the final film you know
at all so you know I I do remember that
first meeting filming that first meeting
and when we put the camera on somebody
who was talking at the meeting several
of them just seized up and got very
quiet and they were like uh does that
camera have to be on me I mean they
there really was that that trying to
grapple with the fact that that there
was going to be a camera in these
meetings that had never had cameras
before they were they been free to speak
as candidly as they wanted without any
concern of anyone else hearing it so
Alex what up what was it like for you to
be out on the streets as part of the
film crew well you know for me one of
the things that I was embellished about
this experience is that I'm usually
working by myself and so if there's
something really gratifying about having
this collaborative effort I mean Steve
and I have talked about this between
ourselves but i can say i don't think
i've ever had so much fun working on a
project before and i think part of it
was working with steve and zack you know
having other people to sort of bounce
ideas off of you know and you know you
begin to sort of have doubts there's
somebody else you say now you know just
we need to go film this don't let's not
worry about it and then the other part
of course was just spending time with
Amina Eddie and Kobe which was both fun
and inspiring not to say they weren't
disturbing moments along the way but I
think for me the real the real
difference between working on this film
and doing my books and magazine pieces
was just that it was collaborative that
they were
you know three of us out there all the
time and if sometimes I get a phone call
about something going on and I call
Steve and I just even I'm not sure
really my Tris really what's going asked
for and Steve would say you know well
with let's do it we were up that's you
know there's midnight let's just go and
do it and so in work both ways that we
had each other to sort of say you know
maybe it's worth going to do this and so
I don't know there was it basically I'm
better get back to my writing and as
much as I'm looking forward to it the
thing that I have a little trepidation
about is sort of going back and sort of
working on my own again and disappearing
from odds you can pay me to go along as
you break out my pad text for a few
minutes you know I mean we touched on it
earlier and I just I just want to see if
we could draw more information you know
because it really is amazing you know
when you watch Steve's work here you
know he just sort of knows where to be
with the camera you know he gets he gets
very close he gets very intimate it's
almost like he's invisible with the
camera and he just gets to the point
where he just exactly were supposed to
be and I wanted there at first direct
this question the Steve to see how he
does it but I think I want to turn it to
you Alex like from what you observed
from being close with him how do you
think I see steve is able to achieve
this effect in the rest films you know I
see it first of all when we began work
on this you know one of the things I was
concerned I had done some TV work before
and I was really concerned and one of
the things that drove me crazy about it
often was just the excessively large
cruise we'd we'd have going out in the
field sometimes as largest six or seven
people I mean it was it was about as
clumsy and as awkward as you could get
and so early on i suggest to deceive
that maybe he consider shooting and
Steve doesn't traditionally though he
shot some of his films he doesn't
traditionally shoot his films and so
Steve ended up doing the camera work
here and you you're absolutely right and
I think one of the remarkable things
about the film is just the visual
intimacy you have with the characters
and that
really accredited to Steve's camera work
and I think that one of the things
that's great about steve is it is he
talked about earlier i mean christy but
it's not about being a fly on the wall I
mean we were constantly talking engaging
with people laughing with them ribbing
them and and so Steve even sometimes
were we in the midst of filming and I
admire this that Steve had the good
sense that you know maybe this is a
moment where he would stop and just sort
of asks here I would you know sort of
assembly questions in the moment which
really got people thinking about what
was going on and some of the I think
some of the best stuff we got was was in
the moment where people sort of as they
were just sort of thinking just on
instinct about what was taking place I
remember Steve early on in the new
probably member this give as well in the
interrupter meetings when we were
filming and steve was would get up
really close to people and you could see
it it made them uneasy and at one point
I remember Akio coming to Steve and
thanks give me do you think you can
maybe pull the camera back a little bit
and stay back a bit and we did for a
while when he was right back great steve
is there anything you can add to your
process and anymore you can share well
no I mean I think Alex was described it
well I think that the key again is is
building those relationships with your
subjects and I've over the years it's
it's also really important who's on the
crew in other words I've always tried to
work with people who are really good
people people not just good at what they
do that that have an ability to connect
with because it's not just you like if
I'm directing and someone else is
shooting and someone else is doing sound
I'm not the only one engaging them ins
and it certainly wasn't the case here
either I mean Alex me and Zack we're out
there together Alex's is taking a lead
on asking questions when we have those
moments or when we do the sit-down
interviews and stuff and
it's just as important that those
relationships be strong between all of
us in the subjects so that people feel
level of comfort because you know it's
it's sort of paradox going away but it's
not when you think about it it I found
over the years that the more you your
subjects feel like they have some
control the more in control they feel of
this process the more open they are then
to revealing themselves that it's when
it's when they feel that you're there
and and that if they do something that
that's a problem for them or is
embarrassing for them or or that they
have a real there sorry you were there
for that they have no control over that
you'll you'll take the approach of oh
well you got it sorry that's the rug
ground rule that's when people start to
lose that that level trust but we were
always very clear with people about that
and those relationships are key you know
but if I'd we had an understanding with
the three or three main subjects in the
very GetGo that they would get to see a
rough cut of the film and obviously we
were handing over editorial decision
making but that if there were things
that they felt somehow compromise them
or others that you know we would have a
conversation about in fact there is a
scene that we ended up taking out of the
movie where Eddie goes back to talk to a
guy now in his 40s who was so Minetti
was much younger was shot and paralyzed
and it was because of that shooting that
Eddie went and sought revenge and Eddie
can't understand why this guy still a
part of the street and there was this
very you know compelling poignant scene
where Eddie goes and kind of confronts
him and outside of a high school and the
guys drinking he's still in the game and
in the end Eddie watched it and just
fell dead he didn't worry about himself
as much as you worried about this guy
and so we ended up you know it was a
hard decision but we ended up but taking
out of out of a film and I think you
know
I thought the best of the collaboration
you know between us but I think the
other part about Steve suggested and
making it feel like this it is a kind of
collaborative effort with your subjects
it's not that they have editorial
control over the cell but you really are
trying to sort of you don't want to put
them in positions that you're going to
leave them vulnerable or compromised in
any way yeah its you really you want to
get to that place where you feel like
you're all making a film together in a
sense and it's you know it's not like
they're going to come to the Edit room
and say you know I think you should put
this shot there that's not going to
happen but but but they feel invested in
it just as you do you know and they're
invested and that's why it's like you
know when people go and make
documentaries one of the questions ask
is you know about paying them and and do
people want to get paid to be in films
and stuff like that and and yet there
are situations you encounter as a
filmmaker where people bring up money
early on and and that's usually a
bellwether if someone is concerned about
are they going to make money from this
that that may not be the situation you
want to put yourself in filming wise for
either of your sake because
documentaries rarely make any money and
of course you can't pay them to be in
your film because that's that would
violate all kinds of journalistic ethics
and compromise the experience but you
know in the case of this film all three
of the interrupter they never they never
brought up money it wasn't until we'd
finished filming and we were in post
that we did what we we typically do
which is we then sat down and said you
know if this film should ever make any
money then we would try and you know sit
down with you and work out some kind of
equitable way for you to share and
benefit from that yeah the day
themselves never brought it up because
they were invested in doing this film
for all the right reasons which was they
cared about this issue they care deeply
about it and and they were intrigued by
the the experience you know of having of
having this experience you know yeah
manetti inside talks about how pathetic
it was for him to be able to talk he's
obviously giving a lot of thought to
what he did and just
finding his way to forgive himself and I
think having these conversations with
Stephen myself and there were a lot of
conversations there over the course of
that year I mean he talks about how it
really sort of helped him sort through
some of that yeah you definitely see
that on camera unfold as we wrap up here
sorry guys we're running out of time but
watching the film we didn't see a strong
police presence in it I know in the
early part there was a scene where some
of the locals claim that the police
showed up and then they were scared
often and drove away did you make an
editorial decision to cut out any scenes
with the police or were they simply not
around well he really weren't they
really weren't they're not really that
much a part of ceasefires work that the
ceasefire maintain certain back-channel
connections with the police in different
situations like the during album one for
example but by and large in their
day-to-day work there they are the
alternative to the police in those
communities that's essentially what they
are and we did make you know we did at
one time talk about wanting to define
more clearly the tensions and and the
ways in which ceasefire connects with
the police in the movie but at a certain
point you know some of that is in the
movie but we decided that that's not
really what the focus of the movies
could be and frankly if we got into that
too much it could create problems for
ceasefire interrupter xin the field for
that to be so explicitly detailed in the
film and the last thing we wanted to do
was in any way undermine the the work
that they're trying to do and so we we
chose instead to focus much more closely
on the work they're doing in the streets
just like we don't really focus much on
the organization as a whole later we're
not you know it's not a film that really
gets into the nitty-gritty of this
organization and all the ins and outs of
how it began and what's it doing we
focus very narrowly on the interrupter
themselves right right and it was kind
of a fine line for us to walk I mean we
we were clear from the outset between
ourselves and with ceasefire that we
didn't really want to make a film about
an organization
per se I mean obviously ceased fire is
central to the movie but really we
wanted to make a film that took his
honest work as we could at the violence
in these communities we do have to
wrapped in my I do want to squeeze this
information and because from seeing the
film we were really wanted to see
evidence of the violence diminishing in
Chicago and yet we came across this
yesterday from January first to Mars
29th of this year there were four
hundred and seventy four shootings a
hundred and one of them fatal and then
the previous year during the same period
346 shootings 55 fatal so you know what
what can we do what what can those
listening do how can we play our part
here you know dealing with this sort of
epidemic that we're facing well I think
we're good yeah there's a lot people can
do I mean in different communities I
mean you can volunteer in mentorship
programs you can contribute to and I
violence organizations that are working
in your in your communities that are
that are trying to do work like this or
related work you can and then of course
you know outs and I feel very strongly
that that the fertile ground for
violence in these communities is is
extends beyond just gangs and in
conflicts it extends to things like the
socio economic realities in these
communities and educational realities or
lack of in these communities and so I
think we feel like there's a host of
ways people can get involved that can
make an impact in those communities
write my music community in which you
can see that window of opportunity just
closing and closing and closing and so I
think once challenges is that how do you
get these issues back a part of public
discourse back to a part of political
debate and I think that's one thing
people can do is find ways to talk
publicly about what's going on in parts
of our cities that was really help that
elected yeah dad has helped it be a part
of that dialogue it's particularly hard
right now to with the economic downturn
then a lot of people are struggling with
and there's I think there's
feeling that well we've got our own
problems we're not going to worry about
those communities when when middle class
communities are struggling in their own
ways which are not the same ways but
what's struggling on the last so it's a
particularly difficult time I think you
know we commend you for your work thank
you so much thank you know we've been
speaking with filmmaker steve james and
alex Kotlowitz of the 2012 independent
spirit award winning documentary the
interrupters for more information on
Steve and Alex please visit the
interrupters dot kardama Quinn dot-com
Alex cod eluates com ceasefire Chicago
org at the interrupters on Twitter and
and and and interrupt us on Facebook
yeah and thanks again guys for doing
this interview I know you've done just a
ton of video and and and an online press
and we appreciate it and and also thank
you for the work that you do and for you
know shining light on situations and
people that you know may not always get
a public voice yeah well things I want
to say to have enough oh you very much
yeah and we'd also like to say thank you
to our guy Ronan Rosser he's someone
that you seldom see or hear a tally talk
radio but he plays a huge part in what
we do so we're very grateful for him
thank you absolutely I'm trying to our
guy um is it Tim Tim yes
horsburgh yes I get that right so Tim
thank you sir thank you too much ones
make sure will you two shut up yes and
we responded we were just blown away
that he was interested in having the two
of them on the show so thank you Tim
we're back here next Sunday on la talk
radio com with YouTube sensation Paul
Yosemite bear vasquez double rainbow the
double rainbow guy Paul's life changed
back in July of 2010 when Jimmy Kimmel
tweeted his dummbell double rainbow
video making him an overnight sensation
we're going to be talking with bear
Vasquez about his youtube channel
various commercials and sustaining an
audience for more on bear Vasquez please
visit Yosemite bear net and on youtube
at hungry bear 956 too and that does it
for us folks until next Sunday have a
great week
you